the good news is there were no bad ideas
why is that good news because well I
can't have a bad idea this the bad news
is it doesn't matter it's not about
ideas this is not about ideas ideas are
not important in dramatic narratives
that's a mouthful to say and gets me a
lot of criticism I was at a scholarly
conference I was telling you that I
rarely go to scholarly conferences I go
to a lot of writers conferences but it
was that an academic scholarly
conference and someone said at a writing
panel this was out of town this was up
in Montana he said you know the problem
with your program at UCLA I really
wanted to hear the rest of this is that
we encourage writers to write
screenplays that are get ready now
because I've memorized this too deeply
encoded into the dominant narrative mode
I'll say it again we encourage writers
to write scream goes in a to deeply
encoded into the dominant narrative mode
so I thought to myself what in the world
and then I I realized narrative is
usually what they say when they mean
story I heard myself say to him because
I was very good because I said you
you mean story and he said yes yes and I
said to him guilty
you're right that's us we we're story
hardliners we think it's all about story
he said what we should be doing is is
inculcating into new writers the the
respect for the value of ideas sounds
great doesn't it but I was saying well
I'm so sorry but we think ideas are
worthless and useless again it doesn't
go over very well but it's the truth
any real writer who who's a serious
writer who has any kind of success will
will tell you it's not about the idea
sometimes when they say oh I got a great
idea MA they really believe that it is a
great idea it's not just an idea in fact
it's a story that's all work now for
example with King's Speech it's not just
a guy who stutters and hires a speech
therapist it's the King of England it's
world war two you know what all of this
as we start to describe it it's no
longer just the idea now you're telling
the story I'm gonna say it again it's so
obvious it's that it's it's hard to see
sometimes things are so obvious you just
can't see them and again here it is it's
all about story that's all it's about
it's about telling a good story
yesterday on the front page of the New
York Times
Bigard about Philip Roth there's no more
successful writer than Roth
he's 79 and he's announcing that he
stopped writing at least stop writing
fiction and I wrote down a quote this is
on the front page of yesterday's
Sunday's New York Times he says writing
is frustration it's frustration
not to mention humiliation that's a
verbatim quote I realized I've actually
memorized it now this is Ross Roth has
had 31 books published 26 novels
published bunches of them have been made
into movies made a great deal of money
has a beautiful apartment on the Upper
West Side he has a gorgeous home in in
Connecticut in the countryside he's had
as much success as any writer has ever
had and he finds it frustrating and
humiliating I mean that's what art is
it's a I've never known any artist who
was worth anything who's really really
satisfied with the work that he did
among the writers were coming to our
program who want to be successful a
majority of them is a hundred percent to
majority I mean every one of them wants
to be a successful professional and
that's what we want them to be we are a
professional school and our great
success is their success they're doing
fabulously well in all media now you
have to assume it's not gonna work out
God is watching if if she sees you take
it for granted that it's gonna work out
then it's not gonna it's not gonna work
out if you need certainty you shouldn't
even start this if you need to know for
sure that you'll succeed at it you just
have to get into the stream and hope for
the best
and at the end of the day let everybody
else betray you and and shortchange you
and let you down but at least you'll be
true to yourself and keep the writing
coming you go you gotta crank the stuff
out you have to keep the stuff coming
that's the most important the most
important part of it yeah being what
does a writer trying to do she's trying
to literally trade her day dreams for
dollars
writer you know that she's trafficking
in her own imagination you know writers
get scolded for what other I'm sorry
other people get scolded for writers for
what writers get praised for an estate
reaming what better than that you know
to literally live on your wits so a lot
of people gonna compete for it and it's
gonna be difficult to succeed at that
but at the end of your life let everyone
else have let you down but at least you
be a warrior for yourself we do rejoice
in an embarrassment of riches here we do
see our students for the most part
succeed and have successful professional
lives but I like to think that they
don't really expect that they certainly
don't take it for granted that that will
come to pass if they do they will they
will not succeed every writer wants to
jump over everything always as including
myself I don't consider myself to be a
terribly important writer although I'm a
much experienced one The Wall Street
Journal calls me
a render of substantial professional
experience and I have done a lot of work
in screen but not only in screen I'm
also the author of best-selling fiction
and nonfiction and I've also written
short films you know commercials
propagate corporate propaganda sales
films films for instructional
educational films the so I'm hugely
experiencing and I still want to jump
over all of the requirements but every
time I try to do that I realize I can't
that it just takes time and you have to
give it the time and that's the most
difficult part of it
because after all time is what your life
is is made up of and I mean time is like
the currency of life if somebody wastes
my time
I feel they've killed me a little bit
you know they've taken part of my life
away and that's what art wants it wants
your life you have to you better be
ready to give your life to this if you
want to be a screenwriter
it sounds cynical and dark but I mean it
the opposite way I can't imagine a more
wonderful thing to give a life to then
creative expression imagine people who
do succeed as writers they're literally
swapping their daydreams for dollars
they're they're trafficking in their own
imagination what could be more wonderful
than that I think it's cause to to
rejoice not to despair
but to rejoice
yeah Oh getting your butt into the chair
your hands on the keys and seeing where
it goes I believe you have to have an
outline but then you got it like a throw
away that outline it will take paths of
a surprises to the the artist that
created it I've never known any buddy
who ever wrote anything that wasn't
surprised who wasn't surprised by lines
of dialogue that the characters seemed
to invent by themselves and twists and
turns in the story I remember asking
Neil Simon do you laugh at your own
jokes and he said sure I do the first
time I hear them and I think that's
fantastic that he actually hears them
it's as if somebody else is telling them
telling these jokes to him and that's
the experience I think of a lot of
artists it's not I wrote a Twilight I
sold a Twilight Zone episode years and
years ago about a muse if some sort of a
composer of commercial jingles and his
muse that proposes if I spare you the
story if I told you the story you think
what a good story but they the the
thesis underneath it was the notion that
muses don't desert their artists it's
really the other way around
you have to be available it's never easy
to get in into and you have to own that
you have to know that I'm not sure that
answers what's the first thing you do
usually something occurs to you that
seems kind of odd you know imagine if
this happened oh that happened remember
when my first child was going to be born
we went to birth classes you know birth
preparation classes which were held at
cedars-sinai and everybody was supposed
to bring a pillow so suddenly outside
you know and then Beverly Boulevard near
San Vicente what is this like all of
these couples all of them women are
quite pregnant and everybody's carrying
pillows you know
that about imagine you know you waiting
you drive piss a bus stop and there's
like 60 people at the bus stop and they
all have accordions
I don't know they've all got accordions
for some reason what could that be and
then you start to think about that and
also you don't think about it you're
just sort of like let it simmer and cook
and maybe an ocean will come to you and
that you start to play with it and and
and see how it unfolds I know there are
other people including people you're
talking to I'm sure who have much more
precise steps I reject that in my own
work and in the work of the writers and
I know again I think that it's a
function of surprise a lot of our it is
and the the important thing for the
artist is to stay open to those
surprises rather than try to drag the
narrative back to some previous
intellectual preconception
my answer that is yes both right yeah
you know they are born but they are also
nurtured that is to say they have to I
think nurturing is a big part of it but
it's really a lot about about discipline
I think a very talent is what you're
born with
maybe discipline can be learned to some
extent relative to the way that you
brought up by your parents and the way
you're taught by your teachers in the
early part of your education but I would
say the most overrated part of the
equation is talent that discipline is
really the important part of it how and
discipline here's here's discipline
here's how you measure discipline that
it's how much time you're willing to put
into this I was talking to right in the
other day who's being told that her
script isn't ready well she's rewritten
it already three times she said well
David cap Cato EPP very very successful
writer who's a former student here he
wrote two of the Jurassic Park pictures
I Spider Man he's a gigantically
successful writer he says the reason for
his success is his ability to get
through seventeen drafts of a screenplay
so um this gunman when I'm speaking to
yesterday doesn't have the discipline
she doesn't want to give it the time
that it that it takes so it really does
take a lot of time and I think that um
it's harder to understand that when
you're really young and easier to
understand it conversely when you're
when you're more mature
in my book essentials of screenwriting I
write about my experience with my father
whom I mentioned earlier he played with
all of the greats of the last century
including Don Pablo Casals the master
cellist
they say he's Spanish he's actually he
would say he's cut too long' and he
lived in Puerto Rico he would not live
in Spain under Franco I live in Puerto
Rico and I went to Puerto Rico to the
Casal Festival visit he's now long
deceased but they still have the cassava
festival back then he was alive he
wasn't playing cello but he was
conducting and I
I watched him teach I saw him give some
master classes and the artists would
come in nervous it's this is Gasol's
you know the master cellist in the world
in his in his day and one of the Google
time masters of cello so you'd see her
play and he would sit there and listen
and I grew up in the world of virtual
world-class music and to me it sounds
you didn't just walk in off the street
to take a lesson you know there was a
shingle it's a music lessons you know
didn't work gotta be really good to
study with Casals so to me it sounded
very very good she'd finish and he would
sit there and he would nod sort of
severely and she'd be really nervous you
could to see the finally he would say
and by the way the first time I saw this
I thought of spontaneous and I realised
he does his every time exactly the same
way it's the way he works the way he
teaches he would finally say beautiful
beautiful and then you could see the
shoulders it's funny cuz my wife and I
just saw Lynne Harrell and the
Philharmonic on Saturday night and it
was beautiful
talk about cello virtuoso celli cellists
and you could see the shoulders relaxed
you know on on the the woman who was on
the nan who was a student in question
and he'd be kind of watching out of the
corner of his eye for that and as soon
as they did
relax then he would say as if it was an
afterthought but really was clearly the
first thing on his mind was perhaps even
more beautiful if the intonation and the
phrasing and he would really take on the
weaknesses and and the shortcomings of
it and some but he'd won the safety of
the artist she felt like he he was on
her side and that is our guiding
philosophy here
I learned the most important lesson of
my life which is the teacher went around
the the classroom asking everybody what
their father did for a living and one
kid's father was a plumber when one kid
swallows electrician this is cleans and
everybody kind of talk like this and my
teacher came and I said my father was a
musician and I remember the teacher
saying no no another one hobbies we're
talking about professions I I said well
my father's super you mean he gets paid
too many as it actually does yes so she
said oh you mean like weddings and bar
mitzvahs I said well I don't think he's
playing any of those gigs quite a while
since he was like a high school kid he
he he works for NBC's with the NBC
Symphony Symphony Orchestra and there
Arturo Toscanini which was a very big
thing you know there's Sunday night
broadcasts in the old radio era you know
or like the hottest item on on radio and
so she was kind of impressed by that and
then she asked me what instrument he
plays and I said bass and she said
what's that what do you mean if so
explain what the bass was that it looked
like a violin but it was much much
larger it stood on the floor and behind
it
and she said oh I know what you're
talking about that's that's called a
cello she said so I tried to explain the
string family to her the violin the
viola the cello in the bass and the
reason I knew that wasn't because I was
precocious although I probably was
precocious but I was like the same
reason if the kid whose father was a
plumber knew the difference between a
hex wrench and a pipe wrench and the kid
whose father was electrician maybe knew
the difference between a voltmeter and
an ammeter I'm just guessing well I
could see she didn't like that she said
wait a second it looks like a violin but
it's much better
that's called a cello huh so I said the
smartest thing I've ever said in my life
it's been downhill for me since that day
in 1950 or 51 whenever it was I said
okay
it's a cello but I knew it wasn't a
cello and I knew more importantly under
two things one people in positions of
authority don't know what they're
talking about and what an authority you
know and it - a kid a six-year-old the
first grader on the first day of school
any grown up is a is an adult
sorry is a any adult is a as an
authority and a teacher is especially in
the Thorin you know an important
Authority so here is this person of
great authority and she doesn't know
what she's talking about
she's just wrong first of all second of
all if you try to enlighten her in and
tell her the truth
inform her of just simple facts gets mad
at you so from that moment on I've had a
disdain and a kind of disregard for
authority and the irony in my life is
that now I'm in a position of authority
there was something that I had with that
I emphasize every day and it is story
it's all about story story is everything
else we were talking earlier a moment
ago about dialogue I also says something
about character well one is dial and
what does character it it's you know the
the stuff that the protagonist or the
other characters in the movie speak and
it's what they do and what they say it's
this it's the story the the richest the
densest the most analyzed and and
studied character and all of certainly
english-language dramatic literature and
arguably world dramatic literature is
Hamlet certainly he's a candidate for or
the number one studied character was he
crazy
or does he feign madness as part of his
scheme to bring justice to his late
father and and his father's memory there
are so many questions that are asked
about Hamlet so many books written about
his character what is the playwrights
description of Hamlet in the play it's
three words Prince of Denmark that's all
Shakespeare tells us about Hamlet so
where does there's nothing about
melancholy for example not in the
description of the character nor
anywhere in the plate as that word
appears so where does this Hamlet guy
come from the answer is what he does and
what he says that's what makes up a
character and again to create a
character like that takes a bunch of
time because it's a story it's really
part of the story it these things don't
break apart into separate discrete
entities but rather have functions
together only when they are linked as
functions of one another
character is story as I said before what
is a character rather than what she does
and what she says okay I have a friend
who is a TV writer and he has a partner
a writing partner they collaborate and
so he told me somebody said to them oh
you guys work to get so like you do the
character and he does the story as if
you could do that separately characters
don't exist outside of stories they
exist only inside of stories again they
are what they like Hamlet they are what
they do and what they say so you can
when people talk about a
character-driven movie they just mean a
good movie okay how about plot driven
but let me just point out to you how
many movies and plays and great classics
are just the name of the protagonist of
the main character for example Hamlet
Lear Macbeth Romeo and Juliet Julius
Caesar
that's just how about go back to the
Greeks Medea Oedipus look at the great
movies The Godfather Citizen Kane it's
not always that way but more often than
not it is the name of the character that
is also the name of the movie the name
of the protagonist and I only mentioned
it in this context because I'm trying to
indicate to you that you can't separate
story and character which is more
important it's like asking somebody
what's more important to you your heart
or your lungs
there's a wonderful book very
underappreciated by a writer who died a
few years ago it's called plots and
characters and by the way plots is first
not by accident and also in Aristotle's
Poetics the first book on dramatic
writing he clearly says plot is what's
really important not character because
again character flows out of plot there
isn't any character outside of a plot
and if there's a plot as automatically
characters that are that are going to be
in it
so once again I just can't hammer enough
on how amateurs feel the taunts don't
get that that it's really about story
and that what you the real work of a
writer is inventing the actions
milord Couchman is the name of the
writer who wrote the book plots and
characters and he has one of the most
timeless brilliant lines in it that I've
ever heard and here it is I've already
said it which is that it is action that
defines character and not the other way
around I'm gonna say it again
it's action that defines character and
not the other way around people who
think it's the other way around are the
kind of people who are doing these
character workshops will invent this a
character who has all these traits and
qualities and characteristics and then
will turn her loose and see what she
does know define what she does tell us
what does she do and that'll tell us who
she is that's true in your dramatic
narrative that you write for the screen
it's also true in your life isn't it I
mean I like to think that I'm a moral
principled reliable decent person but I
look back at what I've done in my life
and I see shortchanging myself and
others disappointing myself and others
constantly frequently acting out of fear
I would say my actions define means
little bit of a coward I'm easily I'm
afraid of a lot of things it's not the
way I want to be but again it's what I
do to the actions the events the
incidents the anecdotes in my life that
tell me who I am and that tell anybody
who who they are and that tell audiences
in movies in movie theaters looking at
the screen that's what tells them who
those characters are Tony Soprano is a
function of what he does he's a vicious
murderer criminal he's also a father and
a husband he's also a troubled man who's
having blackouts fainting spells and
he's he's worried he has so worried that
he does a really worse wimpish thing
which is engages a psychiatrist you know
a therapist a woman on top of that I
mean a mobster a made man and the mob
doesn't do that and all of those things
define for us who he is again it's not
like we've defined the character and
then put them into the situation's we
put in the situation's and then the
situation's define the character
there's a very famous book missin it's
called adventures in the screen trade of
a William Goldman and called unusually
successful writer in its most famous
line the most famous line in the book is
nobody knows nothing because it really
is this is a business where the
exception is the rule and ya just never
know how that's going to come out but
there's a much better line in that book
it seems to me that is overlooked by
most people he's at a meeting Sydney
and the late director is at the
meeting and he wants he Pollock wants to
do a script that bill is written and
they're talking to the money guy in a
restaurant and it's not going well then
a you can see it's not this guy's just
not interested in that film though you
know too risky to whatever you doesn't
want to do it and as it starts to get
worse and worse and this is as described
by Goldman Sydney Sydney says
wait a second I mean reaches for the
script and he and real Goldman
realizes oh my god I don't know he's
actually gonna now read to the investor
the potential investor a passage from
the script and this horrifies Goldman
and he has the line that I'm focusing on
which is now you have to understand I
hate everything I've ever written that's
William Goldman he wrote Butch and
Sundance for God's sake yeah hugely
hugely successful writer there can't be
there are writers that successful as
bill Dolman but none more so artists
should not look back at their at their
work and if they do they're gonna be
disappointed in it
they're not willing to put in the time
that it takes
they have brilliant ideas but as I've
discussed in other places in another
route other videos the most overrated
part of the screenplay equation is the
idea ideas are really pretty useless and
worthless again
[Music]
give me a repeating myself but I am a
one of those people who believes that
Breaking Bad is one of the greatest
achievements in the history of
civilization I think it's really great
great drama so what's the idea that
drives it a high school chemistry
teacher gets a cancer diagnosis and so
he decides to go into the
methamphetamine trade with an
incorrigible former student of his a
criminal you know to sell drugs to
support his family there's a stupidest
idea I've ever heard many many companies
shot that down and yet it is this
triumphant achievement sixty two hours
of a TV series every frame of which is
engaging and and and captivating and
involving and and the so how did that
happen the answer is they told a good
story it's where the story it's really a
little about story that's what we
believe at UCLA that's that's what I
believe a few years I mean imagine if
somebody came up to you and and said I
have an idea for a movie
this guy's stutters but he has to give a
speech so he hires a speech therapist
they work on the species gives a speech
at the end of the movie if somebody told
you that that's gonna win the Oscar for
Best Picture and Best Screenplay you
figure they're crazy and yet that is of
course the King's Speech and again I
think it just demonstrates the the value
of story and the value lessness of ideas
and I think that very young people are
more into ideas they have great ideas I
like to say when you have a great
you have a really really great idea for
a screenplay that's all you've got I
think what remains after that everything
the characters have to be invented the
dialogue they speak has to be created it
has to be punchy and peppy and
provocative and pungent I'm just getting
into peas now and poetic and it has to
be worth listening to
or for itself just because there's
something kind of charming about it but
beyond that it can't be just for itself
it also has to advance the story in a
palpable measurable identifiable way
likewise expand the audience's
appreciation of the characters it takes
time for me to give you an idea about a
movie I can you know takes a handful of
seconds to walk you through the story of
the movie who takes to the length of the
movie a couple of hours so that's where
the value is
people say me yeah but but but Richie
and I was a longer than a screenplay
my last novel and I know I'm bragging it
made the Times bestseller list
okay just number 13 and only for a week
but that's not a small thing
The Times list that was about two
hundred and thirty six pages a two
hundred forty five pages something in
typescript I'm sorry the published book
so in typescript it was about 300 pages
now a screenplay should not be much more
than 100 pages the last bring things are
getting shorter now which i think is
good the last job that I did I had an
assignment this past year and that
script came out I figured 93 94 pages
and it's it's full its complete and my
point isn't the reason I'm dwelling on
these page counts is it's easier to
write a longer thing than a shorter
thing and would seem counterintuitive
but think about it there's a famous
letter that Ernest Hemingway wrote he
was in Cuba living in Cuba and I believe
he was writing the old man of the sea
one of his later books wonderful book of
course everything he did was wonderful
and in the midst of working on the book
he wrote a long letter was nine pages
long to Maxwell Perkins the legendary
editor who worked with a lot of famous
writers including Hemingway and he was
discussing various aspects of the book
and whatever and at the end of the
letter he says well that's about it for
now max please forgive me for running
such a long letter I didn't have the
time to write a short one takes more
time to do what artists have to do which
is to cull and select and throw away so
much screenwriting education is about
structure and construction and building
up and I think there is some useful time
spent considering that but ultimately
creating dramatic narratives is not
about
building um I think it's about tearing
down and taking away it's about
discovery this cover taking the cover
off and finding something that's already
there I never knew her right around I
have a lot of experience myself as a
writer but that experience is leveraged
exponentially by all the writers I've
worked with very intimately very closely
over you know now for 35 years here on
campus with writers in our advanced
graduate screenwriting classes but also
in the community I am a script doctor
I'm a pretty busy script doctor I give
notes to lots of writers no small number
of those writers have deals at studios
they're coming to me and saying you know
ask me the hard questions before the
producer asks I'm becoming more and more
routine I think in Hollywood even when
you have a deal to consult with somebody
before you actually submit it to the to
the studio and so having done that has
it has expanded my own experience as I
say exponentially and I've never known a
writer I've never met a writer who
wasn't surprised by things that happened
in her story by lines of dialogue that a
particular character suddenly spoke it's
as if it kind of has a you know a life
of it of its own
and it is a stupendous screenplay by
cushion and tony was saying a lot of
people think you think the thing up in
your head and then you write it down but
he says the writing down of it is sort
of the thinking of it that there's a
nexus between the pen or the keyboard
the hands on the keyboard that kind of
created and you just never know and you
have to live with that uncertainty you
have to sort of rejoice in and celebrate
and embrace that uncertainty instead of
trying to eliminate the uncertainty you
look at the studio's today or and what's
less interesting than what they're doing
now they're doing prequels and sequels
and items of franchises what they're
trying to do is minimize risk they're
trying to make it so that when a
audience goes to see a movie they get
what they expected but when I go to the
movies I don't want to see what I
expected I want my expectations to be
exceeded I want to be turned upside down
I want to be frightened I want to I want
to life to be changed forever
what it means for writers in practical
terms is to stay open to the surprises
if you have a real idea in advance
exactly how it's gonna go that's gonna
lock you in and narrow you and and stunt
your creativity your character is going
to surprise you they're going to they're
going to do things that you never
thought they would do that they seem to
invent on their own to do and that's
what I was talking earlier about which
is this discovery and that the biggest
mistake you can make is to try to haul
it back if it runs off the the rails a
little bit that's great go with it and
see where that takes you and and be
surprised by be willing to be surprised
by where you end up with it because
otherwise it becomes intellectual it
becomes heady and we need our heads we
need our intellect but not in the movie
theater that's a place where we live not
in the head but heart in the belly in
the groin it's not about understanding
and knowing it's about feeling it's
about it's about passion there's a
really important place in our lives for
rational intelligent expansive discourse
and discussion but not in the movies the
movies is a safe place to work out the
lethal aspects of our nature to go hog
wild and buck naked and crazy as a loon
that's what art is for
get ready to throw stuff away it's again
it's not about building up and
constructing it's about throat taking
down and throwing away writers I like to
tell writers you know you need not
merely to learn that you have to throw
away but you need to learn this is what
maturing is as a writer loving to throw
away you want to see the best thing
that's ever happened to writing
I don't know how if we if we can get
this here it's a cat scan that's a
computer keyboard and I'll just tell you
that if I could get it into the frame I
could point to this key it says delate
that's the best thing that ever happened
for writing and you have to learn that
when you highlight a bunch of stuff you
realize I don't need this cat this line
of dialogue I don't need this seam and
you highlight the whole thing and then
you hit delete in the whole singing
vanishes if you get a good feeling out
of that then your amateur writer it'll
take years and years to get to that most
of the time you're gonna be like well
why you're gonna feel that way bill
because you took time to create that you
believed in it and now you're throwing
it away what about the stuff you're
writing now you're gonna how can you
create anything more if you know that
tomorrow you may throw this away yet
that's what you have to do and the truth
is tomorrow you will throw away probably
not all of it but just most of it and if
you do that eventually you'll have a
whole work you know you'll have old
screenplay
I I have had some modest success in my
career not just in in film working and
making a living as a screenwriter but
also publishing and with major
publishers for the most part in my case
all New York publishers the publishing
business still is mainly New York just
like Hollywood is still Hollywood and
honest' several occasions I I took
something that I had written as a film
and in some instances that actually had
options you made some money on it
but had never really ever gotten it to
where I wanted it to be that is to say a
deal you know that that got made into
something that that audiences could
participate and what I did was use the
novel I'm sorry use the screenplay as an
elaborate outline for a novel I know
writing is easy but it's easier once all
the heavy lifting has been done if he
bunts you've written a screenplay you
know who the characters are you know
almost all of the dialogues certainly a
lot of the dialogue most of the dialogue
the story is all worked out you now have
merely to write it now I was on merely
because there's nothing near about
writing but it is easier to just put the
words on once well you have all of the
incidents of the events and the
anecdotal stuff worked out and then it
becomes a question in the description I
have had success at that that is to say
couldn't make the movie happen so wrote
it is a novel and then sold the novel as
a novel was able to get the novel
publish and then suddenly that was
interest in it as a novel that is to say
an adapted novel adapted for for the
screen the the current my current gripe
with Hollywood with American film
industry is the the refusal to do
original stuff and well you can take an
original screenplay
and turn it into a novel and then it's
no longer original now it's an
adaptation and that's what they they
prefer to do so you can kind of in a
sort of a Zen surrender sort of a way
hey make it what they wanted to want it
to be I also will tell you that I find
greater satisfaction in writing novels
they're less they're easier they're less
they're not easy but they're easier they
are more tolerant of inefficiency and
bad economy I'm not saying you should be
inefficient not economical and when I
talk about economical I mean in terms of
moving story Freight moving character
Freight with a little bit of language
rather than the other way around
and you'll really get killed in a movie
in a screenplay if it's inefficient but
in a novel I think because the the
viewer the reader of the novel has the
opportunity to turn the pages faster or
even to skip over stuff or conversely to
go back and review stuff makes it
somewhat easier for the writer to to
write it down
there are filmmakers out there who are
great at at creating moments that are
exciting and kind of fun to look at the
Coen Brothers for example and I'm not a
fan maybe I'm
I think stuff like this I think that
they are able to kind of dazzle you for
a moment with a crazy wacky thing that
happens and then another one and then
another one but after a while it's just
like a catalogue of crazy things the
difference between them on one hand and
let's say Vince Gilligan and his writers
on the other or David Chase and his
writers on the other hand and I'm
referring to the the founding voices
that drive The Sopranos and Breaking Bad
the examples we're talking about which I
consider to be really outstanding drama
models of great great great dramatic
narratives they create dazzling crazy
things too but they don't just abandon
it and go on to something else they if
you've seen the if you've seen Breaking
Bad you'll see stuff that from the first
season if it gets resurrected three four
seasons later you know it's hard work to
do that you gotta keep track of
everything you gotta make it sort of
coherent you see a movie like inherent
vice I mean you know it's it's just
blabbing you know crazy kind of people
being nutty and they're intense you know
but what's it about and I think they're
largely making it up as they go along I
can't believe that they're not
improvising a lot of that it's takes
work on the part of the writer in fact
it's the hardest work in the world to
create a narrative a story where
everything fits where you where nothing
can be thrown away and there's nothing
in it that you
doesn't serve the story the purpose of
moving that store forward
it's funny app at my class class which
meets tonight in the first class I
always brag about all of the scripts it
got written in the class that became
movies now most of the people who
succeed don't sell the scripts that they
write in the class much less have them
made into movies they use them as
showcase as they win representation they
win development deals and rewrite
assignments and other kinds of rewards
but there are something that actually
been written right in the classes that
became movies and I brag to the eight
writers around the table about those
first thing I do then the next thing I
do is I tell them now please don't try
to sell the scripts that you write in
this class and then I take a long
silence and I let people think about
what seems like a contradiction I've
just been bragging about all those
scripts have sold out of the class and
Here I am saying please don't try to
sell the scripts that you read in class
and I point out to the student that you
write in the class and then I point out
to the writers that it's not a
contradiction I didn't sell don't I
didn't say don't sell the scripts that
you write in the class I said don't try
to sell the scripts to try and place if
you're thinking about the sale while
you're working on it you are doomed you
are lost
you're intellectualizing you're
calculating you're getting in all kinds
of processes that are that will militate
against successful art you're getting
again to intellectual - into your head
when you think that way you start to
think about trends what's popular who
might this be right for I once had a
writer who'd been admitted to the
program it's extremely unusual that
somebody's admitted and doesn't enter
the program our so-called take rate the
percentage of people who are admitted
who actually enroll is like 99 percent
but there was one guy who came to me
with a rude yellow legal pad he'd been
admitted he wasn't sure he wanted to
come and he wanted to know the
percentage of students that had agents
after how much time the median income
for graduates of the five-year mark the
10-year mark not only the medium but the
mean and also the average I resisted
telling him the mean and the average of
the same the median is different but the
mean and the average those are two
synonyms and I said I said I could get
all of those statistics for you that
would show you you know that this is the
best way to succeed in the movie
business to become a writer to come to
this program I said but I don't I'm not
gonna do that
for two reasons the second reason first
the second reason is I'm the professor I
give the assignments I don't do the
assignment he's giving me all these
assignments you know hey dish it out I
don't take it anymore but first of all I
said to him I don't think you will
succeed I hope I didn't say this cruelly
I said it truthfully I said I do not
believe that you will succeed if you
come through this program I if you enter
this program we've admitted you we will
welcome you warmly and we'll treat you
generously but I don't think you're
gonna succeed and he's why I said
because you're sitting here asking me
with a drool yellow peas legal pet asked
me about the median and the main and the
average and the Devin who has the agent
that the one about store in and
character and dialogue and stuff like
that
fames lessons that the sorts of things
that come out of our you know you're
already focusing on the future and how
things are gonna stack up probably not
what to stack up you know and and I was
serious this was not reverse psychology
trying to you know convince them to come
we whenever anybody there's two kinds of
questions I I never answer one is should
I pursue this you know the well the
answer is no if you have to ask then you
shouldn't do this it's too frustrating
again Philip Roth yesterday's took up
times writing is frustration it's
frustration
not to mention humiliation quote close
quote
this isn't some newcomer trying to make
his way through the publishing business
this is the superstar author of the 31
books bestseller after bestseller after
bestseller after bestseller movie deals
up the wazoo
and he says its frustration and
humiliation don't go into it if there's
something else that you can do its kind
of crazy it's not smart I mean I
mentioned that my dad was a bass player
he had great success made a lot of money
and what did was he doing his dragon
horse hair which is what the bow is made
out of it's a tail of a horse a violin
bow or a bass bow of course sheep cut
the strings are made out of the
intestines of sheep and imagine doing
that for living dragging horse hair of
course sheep cut so that it makes a
sound and then claiming that you think
people will pay to hear this sound
they'll line up in the snow and wait
outside for hours to pay big money to
sit in a chamber where for a couple of
hours women and men will do that will
you know blow air through tubes like
flutes and clarinets and so on and I
mean we were I mentioned we were the
Philharmonic on Saturday there's a guy
beating the timpani is somebody doing
bells you know this is like we had soso
seats so they would cost two hundred and
thirty dollars the pair you know I mean
it's crazy Art's not smart it's kind of
dumb and if you're really really smart
you don't go into it this is not for
really really smart people you gotta be
dumber if than that if you want to
succeed in in creative expression gonna
be a little crazy
from beginning to end the least we want
is not to be bored I mean I go to the
movies and see screeners scandalously
I'm going listen let's the theaters and
looking more and more screeners I used
to feel guilty about not going to the
theaters now I feel guilty about not
screening the screeners and and the
reason is usually I am bored I think
most art is is pretty bad most paintings
most sculpture most literature most
music is lousy now that also may seem
like a cynical and a dark thing to say
but it's the opposite of that the truth
is that the the stuff that is
contemporary much of it is going to be
pretty bad some of it will be brilliant
what happens is that it the bad stuff
falls away you go I was in New York not
too terribly long ago and I was in the
Museum of the Metropolitan Museum of Art
one of my favorite museums and I didn't
see a single painting there that wasn't
timeless and eternal that didn't deserve
to be there and you could get the
impression from that that paintings are
somehow worthy all the time oh well you
don't realize a lot of people don't
realize is that for every painting that
hangs at the Met there are 10,000 stupid
worthless jerky amateur paintings now
there's nothing wrong I think it's one
of the people tried to paint and tried
to be creative and took a shot at it but
it's unusual that it's worth bothering
somebody else about event is to say
there's something in the work that
merits the attention and the
consideration of the time of an audience
an observer in film because it is
contemporary even more so television
because it's in our face now there
hasn't been the chance for the stuff the
bad stuff to drop away so we think that
it's uniquely bad when it is and it's
just as bad as other as other art
fortunately the little bit of really
really good stuff is enough to change
your life and and make it worth engaging
all of it all of the stuff so that you
do see the the the good stuff
there's people people say why don't they
make good movies now like they used to
in the 30s and the 40s
did they make good movies in the 30s and
the 40s they did there were a lot of
really good ones but they were also a
lot a lot of lousy ones we just don't
remember them I think 50 60 years from
now they'll be saying why don't they
make good movies like they did back in
the early you know new millennium
because the people will have forgotten
[Music]
the Hunger Games I I'm not a big fan of
the I think people are gonna forget
about it but they're going to remember
the imitation game they were into games
today I guess isn't that the movie the
yeah about touring and so on so we the
least we want when I say don't be boring
I'm saying that's the very least that I
want from a work of art we're talking
about dramatic narratives you know if
you see I was at the Louvre in Paris and
I saw the the Mona Lisa among others
how much time did I spend with it a
minute if I'd spent three minutes with
it that would have been a long time if i
sat quietly now for just a few seconds
you'd feel how how heavily time ways do
you know I'm just waiting for see if I
get quite even for two seconds you get
nervous and you jump and I don't blame
you that's my that's my point I say
sorry no no no not at all that's you
help you you're helping me the the but
the most we want from that's the least
we want I have a deal with my wife which
is if I start to nod out during movie
she's supposed to let me do that unless
some snoring and wheezing and spraying
everybody around us and then bringing
disgrace and discredit and humiliation
upon us it's up to the movie to keep me
awake and the the faculty matter is that
I used to like fight it if I started to
drift during the movie I would fight it
like you know Hey so what a breath in
China you know pay to choose now I if I
start to drift that's it I'm going I'm
gonna not out in this one it's not worth
seeing you know I've walked into movies
where I was really weary hadn't slept
very well but it was a good movie and it
woke me up so that's the least we want
don't be boring and if that's all you do
that's an incredible achievement but
again that's the bottom that's what's
the top and the top is I want my life
changed completely the way great art
does I want it turned upside down and
transmogrified I want to be transported
and that's what Breaking Bad did to me
that's what the Sopranos did to me I
just my life is different and you know
constantly because of my exposure to to
that that great art and that's what
great art should do at the top end it
should just change your life forever
there's this expression on Broadway they
don't come out whistling the scenery
you can't people don't go I love
beautiful cinematography but if that's
all you have it's really really old in
about five minutes there's got to be a
story it's all about story I'll tell you
in the earliest days of movies 100 years
ago now about 110 years ago
well actually going back almost 130
hundred 40 years to the invention of the
motion picture camera Thomas Edison and
all of that the very first image ever
the very first moving picture image ever
recorded is a trolley a trolley car
moving down the Main Street of Orange
New Jersey why in the world how did that
in the world did that come to be the
first a moving picture image and the
answer is first of all that's where
Edison's studio was and when he was
finished building the camera he needed a
lot of light so he went outdoors and
wanted a photograph something moving you
don't invent a moving picture camera and
then try it out on a vaz with a rose in
it you know you want something that
moves well they have trolley cars going
down the Main Street there and at that
time in that town in New Jersey and so
he photographed that and for a number of
years people would just blown away they
was stunned to see a picture that moved
but very quickly that became wearying
all right been there done that
adios so then they started to have
scenes moving pictures from all around
the world from the great you know the
wonders of the world some of the very
earliest moving picture images are of
benin tribesmen in flowing robes riding
camels past the pyramids at giza in
egypt the Great Wall of China with
Chinese indigenous Chinese making their
way with carts along the wall on the
wall next to the wall
the they shot very very early images of
Victoria Falls or in South America
Iguazu Falls with Amazonian natives in
their native garb this great cascading
waterfall so people were were excited to
see that stuff for a little while you
know because it wasn't just moving but
it was famous stuff you no longer had to
bother to go to Egypt to see the
pyramids you could watch it and in a
movie theater I think probably it's a
better experience to see it in person
but the point is after a while everybody
was bored with that after a very little
while and then comes nineteen oh two or
three or four or five I don't remember
exactly when and it's the the Great
Train Robbery suddenly it's a story
I'm narrative that's been creative then
that they made up likewise the male gay
brothers in France doing trip to the
journey to the moon trip to the moon
whatever it was called an actual story
that they made up and that they filmed
everything has changed since then
movies are no longer shorts they're long
they're no longer in black and white
they're in color they're no longer
silent they have sound nowadays with
with mobile you know with mobis ODEs TV
series is all different kinds of lengths
of films so there's been a tremendous
amount of change but one thing has not
change does not change in a hundred and
ten years and that is story it's all
about narrative it's all about story now
and that's what will get people to to go
to the movies not some technical
achievement but a creative artistic
achievement that is again the creation
of a dramatic narrative the telling of a
story it's all about stories